that looks pretty big yeah he's like
dude
it's way better now
put me down
[Music]
all right this is gonna be another JK
Mystery episode you gotta figure out
what happened here
they're uh out in Minnesota they found
up to 11 bald eagles lying face down in
the snow illegal breeding not dead wait
just like yeah just lying face down the
snow you mean like head in the snow like
a [__] mass suicide they're alive he
said they're like with their wings out
like this yeah are they sleeping they're
not sleeping they're they're a little
sick but like what happened to them sick
but their heads in the snow yeah they're
just like this they got headaches so
they're trying to chill it yeah body
temperature is rising they're doing whip
off
it's a pretty crazy
um scenario what happens is that to do
with Sirius X FM radio
oh it's close it's close whoa so they
were drugged yeah it's close
the drug you think of it's It's a drug
ax body spray oh oh oh they they were
they were they ate some mushrooms on
accident they were tripping out oh
that'd be way more they were gumen
they're goobing off camera conversation
don't worry about what the [__] is
guming so they got the him was educated
me that's when you're on shrooms I don't
know they got hold of uh a drug called
pentobarbital
Pinto barbasol okay oh that was just
high it's not what it is is it's
pentobarbitals what they give like uh
when you're on the death you get the
death penalty and they execute you oh
[__]
how do they get that because oh so do
they give that same thing to putting
animals to sleep yeah wow yeah somewhere
somewhere in Minnesota they were putting
animals to sleep using this drug and
they were throwing them into the
landfill oh bald eagles because they
feed on carcasses found some fresh
carcasses that were thrown out on the
open landfill they decided to eat the
eat and they got the penobarbital in
their system oh and then they were just
mid-flight and was like head dive in the
snow Yeah so then they're just because
it's like secondhand Pinto Bob it's all
it's not entirely killing them but it is
like they're [__] up oh because they
were eating the old animal box yeah they
ate the animal bodies that had pets I
didn't know Eagles were [__]
scavengers me neither I thought they
were [__] hunters
and then they catch a ratchet up animals
dude they'll snatch up dogs and [__]
snatch anything up yeah yeah but I
thought they were like more like get
live animals not [__] not like a
vulture they probably do both yeah they
probably do both they're hungry yeah
maybe both or maybe that was such a
fresh like throw like they were like oh
you know what's one thousand I was like
watching like uh eagle hunt oh my damn
nature is beautiful man it is yeah when
like the eagles hunting a duck or some
sort of like water bird it has to time
itself right and right when it gets
close the defense mechanism of the water
bird well like Duncan's head or go
underneath water and it's doing that
because
this animal knows that the Eagle's
feathers if it gets soaked with water
it'll get waterlogged oh if the Eagles
can't go in the water but the water
birds that are the prey they won't get
waterlogged so their feathers are even
built different it's just crazy how
Nature Made this almost like Perfect
Balance where extreme Predator but this
is the Kryptonite and this is a prey and
it is the way you can get safe wow God
works mysterious ways wow that's
beautiful yeah but then how the how is
the eagle gonna eat them they gotta time
it
you ever seen the Purdue speech the
Eagles can eat other stuff too
it's like when you watch The Deadliest
Catch it's just a different version of
like what we're trying to eat is all
make it so hard because they're like you
gotta work for your food and then they
catch and they're like ah this one
missed and then they go again oh this
one they go I got one [__] and then
it's like they eat yeah that's fishing
that's fishing explain it I imagine like
the one Eagle being like hey you guys
sick of hunting I know this spot it's a
bunch of just dead animals
fresh bro they do the good for you like
Korean barbecue right
it's like going to your uncle's Auntie
spot though you open the fridge like
this is expires I'm like it's not
expired it's just you know it's a little
mature smell it
but you're just dead
and no all the other [__] like should
we trust Fred [__] it let's trust me all
right cool and then he either like [__]
man I don't feel good
what you do friend and one of us is just
put your head in the snow it'll feel
better
and they all just start doing it but
yeah honestly it's kind of funny it must
be a crazy scene to pull up to right
yeah it's bizarre because all of them
were nursed back to health like they
were able to locate all the bald eagles
out they were all together no they were
they were separate they're all tracked
every single one is they found up to 11.
they don't know if there's more there
could be more of them but I could
imagine every bald eagle being attacked
in America hell yeah dude they're in
danger they're in danger yeah how big
are they because I heard that they're
massive but they're big dude they're
probably this tall bro I saw one of the
big ones I'm guessing I'm guessing five
foot wingspan that's what I'm guessing
there's a here's here's like for scale
here's a dude holding it okay oh that's
the head right there yeah he's trying to
go on the snow right now it looks pretty
much
have you guys ever seen Alaska like
footage of bald eagles
they look kind of boring okay golden
eagles are the tight ones no cause like
when you're looking at normal [__] right
when you see one ball of Eagle you're
like damn that [__] got a white
head and [__] that's crazy but then when
you see Alaska one and you see 12 of
them in a tree you're like you guys
ain't special oh because they're not
scarce okay first of all that's America
right there that's a pillow my boy I'm
sleeping on a pillow here
because I'm never doing pentobarbital
again
know your limits yo Fred what the [__]
man
yeah he's just good Freddy you [__] me
friend hey what if there's
oh yeah what would they like do you get
addicted like they might be down like
that but they might be like this [__] is
kicking or they're having some like an
Ayahuasca vision and they're like bruh
we gotta top rooting for America dude we
gotta stop rapping for America man
there's
just like damn dude
we ain't even ball the exactly
damn that would be so funny
but yeah I thought that [__] would kill
them straight up but it didn't wow
that's how resilient these guys are
America are they even endangered anymore
they are huh I don't know not at the big
bears not in Alaska got too many of them
yeah for real they'll probably have open
season for a little bit huh to quell
them
I do think it's a interesting concept
that it's always like like this animal
is the top of the food chain but it's in
danger was at the top of the food chain
it's endangered king of the jungle
indeed because of the demands of the
zoos man cause the poachers bro cause we
stupid yeah so if an animal gets
endangered not because of humans do they
still try to preserve it the same way or
are they mainly doing it as reparations
because we [__] up it depends if white
people care about it yeah okay like if
it's cute so it needs a good documentary
yeah everything needs a good documentary
like Telecom from [__] Blackfish the
only endangered animals that Asian care
about are the pandas I don't think they
talk about anything else yeah what what
is that animal it looks like an
armadillo low but like penguin no the
one that they [__] for kovid Pangolin
Pangolin yeah the ones that basically
they take like what is the same as Nails
right yeah yeah their scales are like
nails or a cuticle nail type [__] I saw
them [__] I was like [__] just
eating [__] armadillos they eat
armadillos no no no it's the pangolins
they eat pangolins who eats pangolins
Chinese people that's how they get Kobe
dude
you can't say that
no but there was news there was news
that came out and said actually it's not
a bat it's a Pangolin you like you
didn't even know what talking about
right now no they did because because
we'll talk about Mickey Mouse [__] a
penguin or something yeah because South
Park made a joke about it but it's
because there was news coming out saying
like oh it's actually not a bat it's a
Pangolin really dude yeah back when they
were trying to Freestyle the cause yeah
right just give it anything everybody
had it speaking about [__] ironic
Mother Nature that's what that's [__]
up for Penguins right it's like penguin
got all this armor and [__] like that
they're like built all like I got
[__] scales that protect me but then
if they're in danger they curl up into a
ball like a roly-poly and the humans
just pick their ass up drop it in a pot
just boil it
still at a market these are easy to
catch these are opposable thumbs [__]
wow that's [__] up that's true that's
why the dodo bird became extinct why
because that Island was had no Predators
so they never developed any type of
defense mechanism or fear so when the
humans rolled up with their dogs and
[__] they're like yo these birds they
don't [__] run away so they just Club
them over the head and they had like
dodo jerky and [__] that's sad that's
good meat they made dodo fried chicken I
bet she does taste good dude I'm not
gonna lie [__] like dodo Fried
Chicken
they use the dodo to season the chicken
I like how you replace that Kentucky
with dodo instead of chicken fried
chicken but DFC 11 herbs and spices
they're not even eating it they're using
it to season other animals you could
grind it up oh [__]
they like get rid of the whole dodo bird
and just use his beak and crumple it up
but they got to do it like this social
media yeah exactly what are we talking
about before that like when they're
gonna start making lab meat you could
have like endangered Meats you're not
you're not actually like that in the
population that's crazy no they can't
even make the beef taste like beef yet
so what the [__] are you talking about
what is impossible Burger fake me that's
impossible is is exactly like uh the
other it's it's just planted beans yeah
it's not lab grown it's not lab girl
does it it doesn't taste like beef lab
grown is essentially just meat it's
actual meat but it's just like a stem
cell yeah oh you know what I mean like
they'll take a cell of like a actual cow
and they'll grow like a random slab of
nothing meat that's wild so it's not
even really like it won't even be a
specific cut it's just like
weird you know what I think would be
good that we eat what invasive species
meat what's that so like a lot of the
wild pigs like iguanas they're not
supposed to be there yeah like boars
yeah and then like if you put your
efforts into just
helping that environment clean up by
like grabbing up all the invasive
species and then like eating them
hi gawanna it'll run out though so you
wouldn't eat a lab-grown saber-tooth
tiger I don't wanna I wanna try
everything yeah yeah definitely
[Music]